well it means a lot of Christina
directly is lot of suffering it's a lot
of losses and bankruptcy foreclosures
are expensive for for everybody they're
they're a very costly way of resolving
that they the lender loses money the
borrower is has his or her life
disrupted it's very very bad thing
that's the question we all have is how
much is this going to slow the economy
how much you know you are we talking
about a recession and the answer which i
can say with great confidence is nobody
knows it's it's very difficult to pin
these things down it certainly slows the
economy and we will be seeing again I
think I think the economy is going to be
sluggish for for a long time to come
because of the housing whether it's
enough to tip it into into something
that will meet the official definition
of a recession I think the odds are less
than even but it's still pretty it's
going to be nasty is going to feel going
to feel it already to most people feels
like a like a bad economy
you